organiser une primaire de la gauche pour
la présidentielle 2022 c'est vraiment
pas une mince affaire et pourtant par le
passé ça a plutôt marché
[Musique]
précédemment dans l'histoire de la
gauche il ya cinq ans une primaire
réunis socialistes radicaux de gauche et
écologistes modéré sept candidats
s'affrontent et veulent faire entendre
leur différence souvenez-vous les
propositions que je formule sont des
propositions qui réunit filet
différentes gauche la gauche sociale la
gauche du travail la gauche morale et
des valeurs la gauche entrepreneuriale
si je suis d'ailleurs candidat dans
cette primaire c'est à la fois pour
rassembler les socialistes qui ne
pourront pas se rassembler si ce n'est
pas moi qui fais ce rassemblement et
après continuer ce rassemblement 2
mélenchon à mâcon pensant bien entendu
par yann exalté le courage de la vérité
nous fassent eux aux français c'est le
refus de la démagogie oui ou non
aujourd'hui on a une politique vis-à-vis
des migrants qui est une politique
d'abord sur humaine humaine une
politique qui s'assure que quand les
migrants viennent chez nous on leur
donne les conditions pour s'intégrer
c'est benoît hamon qui a remporté cette
primaire en 2017 il est investi candidat
à la présidentielle mais très vite ça
tourne mal certains de ses petits
camarades le lâche et puis doit faire
face à la montée d'un autre candidat de
gauche jean luc mélenchon au final
benoît hamon récolte 6 % des voix au
premier tour échec cinglant mais dans
l'histoire il y à une primaire qui a
plutôt réussi à la gauche
cette année là une primaire citoyenne
est organisée par les socialistes c'est
la première primaire ouverte de
l'histoire ça veut dire que tous les
citoyens peuvent voter et ça marche près
de trois millions d'électeurs se déplace
au premier tour et au second tour place
au match entre martine aubry et françois
hollande entre la gauche forte et la
gauche mal quand je parle de gauche
forte la force quand même une bonne
chose c'est comme la solidité ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faut dire les choses
clairement et moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le débat c'est
gênant entre nous c'est le flou je crois
que c'est cela qui peut gêner les
électeurs moi je ne sais pas ce que
c'est que la gauche dure je n'ai pas
envie d'ailleurs d'une gauche dure très
franchement on sort de cinq ans d'une
présidence brutale et on serait nous une
candidature sectaire je ne veux pas je
pense que le pays a besoin d'être apaisé
réconcilié je sais pas non plus une
gauche molle on n'a pas besoin
là d'une gauche timide il faut une
gauche qui soit solide et le plus solide
c'est françois hollande qui gagne cette
primaire et qui a été lu quelques mois
plus tard président de la république
allez on va revenir encore cinq ans en
arrière pour cette élection
présidentielle les socialistes font une
primaire fermée seuls les militants
peuvent voter trois ténors du parti se
présente laurent fabius dominique
strauss kahn et ségolène royal et c'est
la première fois que le débat d'une
primaire pour la présidentielle est
diffusé à la télévision et ça s'est
passé sur les chaînes parlementaires en
exclusivité démocratie participative oui
mais démocratie représentative et
surtout ne pas
épouser une espèce de populisme qui
serait extrêmement dangereux et qu'ils
feraient le lit de l'extrême droite si
on a peur du peuple si on a peur des
jurys citoyens parce qu'on va tirer 15
personnes au sort et on se les élus se
sentiraient mis en cause pour qu'il y
ait de la confiance il faut s'engager
à ne promettre que ce qu'on pourra tenir
au final c'est ségolène royal qui
remporte cette primaire avec son
programme pour une démocratie
participative et ensuite elle va
jusqu'au second tour de la
présidentielle
elle récolte 47% des voix face à nicolas
sarkozy on va pas se mentir aujourd'hui
la gauche rêverait de faire un tel score
encore faut-il se mettre d'accord pour
désigner un seul candidat
[Musique]